[Musique]
léo n'est pas comme les autres il est
sur le point de se faire des amis
vraiment pas ordinaire
[Musique]
tu sais remettre tout ça en plein
j'espère existe à domicile avec lui on
sait pas faire ça mais il en sait rien
ou cherchent à acheter un de ses neveux
de vie quoi
à tapis de massage super c'est votre
dernière chance trick 13 le b2b mission
audacieuse leurs pouvoirs incroyables
fronsac règle écoutons à l'église qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire en cuma
plus j'aime donner du bonheur à lui en
non le principal ouais l'atomiser c'est
ça on sait toujours pas comment faire
retrouver c'est ça je suis la femme de
ménage non je suis la femme de ménage
ensuite aventure je lui dis bien tout
simplement drôle est fabuleux c'est
n'est pas un petit morveux tu vas à se
moquer de moi rien n'est pas un dingue
c'est un vrai pionnier du seuil
au-dessous du jour faisait déjà nous et
tendez les eaux et les extraterrestres
bientôt au cinéma